[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for
espn senior nba insider host of the woj
podcast
adrian wojnarowski woj thanks for
joining us uh can you explain
what the super max rules are that was
there any
kind of leverage or like luca was
getting 207 million no matter what
that's right dan and what what's
different about lucas
super max off of his rookie extension
that
you know you've seen other rookie
extensions and you see the
the 207 million dollar number or
202 last year 195 based on where the
salary cap is
he's the first player to sign this deal
who's already
fulfilled the requirements to get to
supermax so you have to make all nba
or win mv i think it's all in all nba
mvp or uh maybe even defensive player of
the year
any combination of those in two out of
three years
earns you that 30 of the cap which takes
you from
essentially 175 to 207 so
luke is the first one to sign this deal
having
already been all nba twice other great
young players tatum and donovan mitchell
trey young they can earn that 200
million
uh in their deal if they become all nba
twice
luca's the first one who's already done
it at 22 years old twice
before he signed the contract why did
everybody jump on mark cuban's
jet and go to slovenia for the signing
including
jason kidd if it's a foregone conclusion
like did they have to
massage him a little bit nurture him a
little bit here
i think it's just a sign of respect of
what he means
to that organization that they would
come and do it collectively
and uh you know formally present it to
him
there was going to be a press conference
later today in slovenia but i think it's
just
because of who he is what he means to
the organization
you know we're not going to um do
anything
but but be buttoned up come see you
present it tell you what you mean to us
and
and uh uh and haven't signed the
contract i i wonder
and as many people as you talked to can
the mavs
build a championship team around luca
and and if so how do you do that
well that you certainly can't build one
around him there's no question he is
this is a future mvp
in the league probably multiple mvps
before he's
done um yeah i said listen i think
the progress of chris epps porzingis
and his health i think mentally just
i think embracing that role alongside
luca
how this goes now with jason kidd those
are going to be really important
uh factors and they traded for porzingis
with the idea that this was going to be
you know a legit number two co-star and
health has played
a lot of uh uh has been a lot of the
factor of why he's not been
as effective they need him to get
healthy uh but certainly they need more
they're not there yet they've been
knocked out in the first round twice
uh by the clippers uh but luke is 22
years old
and we can look at the progression of
other great players in the league
you know giannis the struggles he went
through finally winning it at
uh 26 right this year yeah so
it's not probably next year it's not the
year after i think we
we see how these things evolve you know
it is rare that you're going to win a
title with your best player at
22 23 24 even when it's someone of
of the talent of luca doncic are the
lakers done with moves
well i think certainly significant moves
i think there's still
some room to add another veteran minimum
player to their roster but but this is
largely the team they'll have and you
saw them go out in free agency because
of the westbrook trade
and trading essentially three for one in
that deal
losing caruso to the bulls you know they
had to fill out their roster
and you kind of saw a combination of
some players who had been there before
older you know they get a couple four
men and carmelo anthony trevor ariza
uh come there dwight howard comes back
as a as a center for them and then a
couple younger
guards malik monk uh kendrick nunn comes
from
uh miami so uh
like when you're the lakers you can get
some guys
to take that veteran minimum uh
deal you know who might maybe might be
able to make a little bit more elsewhere
but you go there on a one-year deal you
have a chance to to win a championship
you can increase your value and i think
that's what a couple of those guys are
counting on
what do you think the uh the league
reaction is to what the lakers did
listen i think uh listen i think the
people know that the lakers
you know were formidable last year
they'll be formidable again health is
going to play a big part in this
and regardless of the role players
around their stars
lebron james anthony davis you know
listen
health played a huge part in why that
team um
got knocked out and they lost to a very
good phoenix team and who knows maybe at
full strength phoenix still wins
that series we won't know but certainly
lebron
now you know you know past i think he'll
be 37 right in the playoffs next year
uh anthony davis coming off of a
significant injury
keeping those guys healthy is you saw it
last year in the postseason and you saw
the team's milwaukee
for the most part was able to stay
healthy they did lose divincenzo
you know health played a huge factor i
think when there was this such attrition
around the league
coming off of in that condensed schedule
and
i'm sure that'll be the case next year
but this is an la team
especially because of lebron's age
you've got to go for it every year
and now they bring in russell westbrook
uh who
uh listen is going to bring a lot to
that team
they still have to surround that group
with shooting
that's not what russ does russ is not
going to be a catch and shoot guy
uh when the double teams when when
lebron kicks it out
russ is going to still attack the rim
and so it's a different dynamic for them
what about dennis schroeder who turned
down that extension and now
there's a report this morning that maybe
he'll sign with the celtics
could could the lakers have done a sign
in trade with him to get something in
return
they could do one um if that interested
them that they have the ability
i've not sensed that's been something
for them that
because remember somebody else has to
want to give up something of value and i
think teams
you know there's teams who can sign
schroeder probably not not certainly at
the number that he could have had with
the lakers
but i haven't gotten the sense since
free agency's really
gotten rolling that there have been a
lot of sign and trade scenarios again
if the lakers are going to take somebody
on and they're in the tax remember that
player is going to cost them
exponentially more
because of the tax bill you know you've
got to think that
the guy whose contract is probably going
to be two or three times
what he makes on your tax bill is that
worth taking on
um and so and again
teams don't i don't think they feel like
they've got to give up something of
great quality
to bring in dennis schroeder now they
can sign him if they have their
mid-level exception
that taxpayer mid-level which is around
6 million they can sign them to that
is there any chance that a an owner
could just say i don't care about the
tax ramifications like steve ballmer has
how many billions and billions of
dollars that like the yankees they just
said we don't care what the luxury tax
is did
could you see an nba owner going rogue
and just saying
hey go i'll pay it i'm but i well
i'm gonna blow through the stop sign
yeah i mean we've seen it i mean golden
state's tax bill
has been enormous i mean they brought in
kelly ubre last year
and his salary i think he cost them
trying to remember
just ubra's salary was over i think 50
million dollars when you put the tax
that's commitment that that's a lot of
money for kelly ubrey
in a year where you prop well you know
you're not going to win the title
without klay thompson last year
uh listen brooklyn's tax bill is going
to be enormous the lakers are going to
be and see bomber and
with the clippers once they resign uh
kawhi leonard so
i think teams have gone significantly in
it
you know if you remember prokhorov in
brooklyn early on with the nets they
didn't have success
it was no object to them so i think
we've seen it
you know i guess it's all relative to
you know how astronomical it goes
but there comes a point where you're
locked in by the cap or you just can't
you can't just keep adding big salaries
you're essentially
um the cap doesn't work necessarily
that way where you get locked in at
certain slots and so you're just paying
you know a ton of tax for a guy making
three or four or five or six million
that doesn't mean he's a great player
and it makes any sense to do it
did you trademark woj
no not that i know of you should
probably do it today
why is something happen well i don't
know i just i just think you just go
with one name
like i think you've you've earned that
sting prince
madonna woj yeah i
hadn't thought of it uh in that grouping
but um
uh but yeah that's something i'll uh
i'll i'll check into this afternoon dan
that's a bad idea
okay not this morning but this afternoon
you will
that's right after lunch and trademark
loge bomb too
well there you go okay okay i haven't
thought any of these things thanks damn
all right thank you
that's uh be well thank you adrian
wojnarowski
i'm just helping out that's all